while McCready district needs more civil
defense volunteers if you're 18 years or
older you can join us and help protect
our community our welfare team supports
those who cannot look after themselves
during emergencies we do information a
shoulder to lean on we could be assuring
them with banquettes sorting out bid
anybody in the community can can join us
our sector post teams scan their local
areas for people who need help and for
dangers to the community getting
information out to people what's the
local situation what's what things are
expected to develop it's rewarding to be
able to help them through that situation
our rescue team engages in a wide range
of emergency tasks and carries out
rescues if you got a hint of interest
then it's well with you know coming down
to our open night it also has a cadet
program for those aged 15 to 18 years
which provides hands-on rescue training
and excellent life skills basic
first-aid ropes training how to respond
to floods and storms it's really
interesting finding out what we do
there's so much that we do that people
don't know about come to our information
night on Wednesday the 1st of March at 7
p.m.
meet our teams and find your place come
along and find out it's not all physical
it's not all mental it's simply a case
of being trained up to be able to help
out when things go up support your
community in emergencies and volunteer
with solder fiends